the first ones Victoria this talk is
gonna be about information theoretic
trade-offs in control and the
considering here is the following
suppose we want to control a system over
a rate constraint link such as a
wireless communication channel for
example if you a person who is standing
on the ground and trying to control a
flying drone then it really matters how
many bits you are signing over this
channel because it's rate limited link
or you can envision a scenario where you
have two systems talking to each other
again over wireless so it's rate
constrain together trying to coordinate
their actions
communication and I'm gonna for the most
of the talk I'm gonna be focusing on the
linear system linear Skylar scalar
system so this is a toy toy example here
we have a system state X which was
according to this linear equation and
everything here is scalar VI is the
disturbance which is modeled as a random
noise which can be potentially unbounded
and UI here is the control action the
goal here is to bring the state as close
to zero as possible and a here is a
known system parameter which is known as
system gain
okay
so a here is a system gain which is a
known scalar and
yeah and we also assume that we know the
distribution of the noise and just for
now we assume that noises III D okay so
I didn't they are analog so they have
some density so that's the identically
and independently distributed so here's
the setting so this is our system which
evolves according to this linear
equation that I showed earlier and the
in color here observes the state which
which is then used to form a code word
which is transformed to the controller
transmitted to the controller over this
channel and the controller I chooses a
control action u based on all the
information it had received up to that
point so what we would like to do the
Holy Grail here is to choose the
encoding sequence so to design this in
color and to design the controller which
means that we want to choose both of
these sequences so as to minimize the
cost which is in this case the mean
square error cost as we want to bring we
want to bring in a state to to the
target location and without loss of
generality here we assume the target
location is zero and so I want to bring
it to zero and the the quality of our
control is measured by this mean square
error cost function
the important thing here to note is that
is that this incoming and and control
sequences we do not impose any any
restrictions on them
apart from them being causal so they
cannot look in the future but they can
freely use all the information from the
past ok and channel and system here are
given
whereas encoder and controller is what
we can design for this given channel and
for this given system and yes I said I'm
gonna be mostly talking about this
killer model but all the results
actually easily generalized to a vector
case which is more relevant for practice
it's so for vector case we have
everything
reactor here and and a becomes a matrix
and and we can also have a cost function
which is called linear quadratic
regulator so yes so you could think of
it this way so imagine that X contains
not only the location coordinates but
also lets acceleration and velocities
and perhaps we want to bring the
location to zero but we don't we don't
want to do it with very high
acceleration or is very high velocity
and so we have different constraints on
those different coordinates and this can
be captured by this Q matrix and then
similarly we can also have a cost on
this you save energy right so we want to
penalize a larger control actions so
with a standard standard setting called
linear quadratic Gaussian control so
usually people look at the Gaussian V is
also here we'd not put that restriction
there's been a lot of prior work in this
area so it's the relatively well
researched area how are some very basic
questions I left open and this is
actually what attracted me to this area
so this is quite significant research
effort however these are all difficult
questions so it's a lot of a lot of
things I left unanswered and okay so
what we are after here is we would like
to characterize this curve so this is a
cost that we can I achieve versus
channel quois so channel quality in this
talk actually I'm going to be focusing
on noiseless channels so channel quality
seen in that scenario would be just rate
so the transmission rates over over this
noiseless channel or noiseless channel
capacity so data rate number of bits per
second that you are transmitting and so
so we expect this curve to look
something like this and right so the
channel quality deteriorates the cost
the minimum are achievable cost
increases and vice versa and yeah also
there are two interesting assume to this
so the vertical one which is the
standard control setting without rate
constraints and the horizontal assumes
that average which is the minimum
channel quality to guarantee stability
so to guarantee any bounded cost and
actually in this talk I'm going to be
mostly talking about about about this is
a simpleton
okay so let me try to explain why this
is a difficult problem so this is a
problem which lies at the intersection
of information theory and control right
because we are talking about control
over a communication channel and and it
seems natural that we would to solve
this we would want to bring together
tools from information theory and
control however traditionally this two
fields evolved for different settings
right so a typical in a typical
information theory problem we would
encounter stationary in memoryless
sources and channels our design control
we our sources so for example the Nina
system that you saw it it actually has
infinite memory about the past so there
is no memorylessness there also
information theory we usually have block
coding so we can afford to wait for
let's say thousand bits and then encode
those bits whereas in control it's
really important that we have short
delays so we cannot I cannot have this
luxury of waiting and introducing this
coding delay because because the system
so we have this system right here and
this a is in unstable system this is
going to be greater than one so it's a
it's a non-stationary process so if we
if we make it just be uncontrolled so if
we put you to zero then it's gonna it's
gonna blow out go blow up so we don't we
don't want this to happen so we don't
want to delay the system relative to
allow ourselves to code so what we want
to do here then is it's something like
convolutional coding where we were
constantly outputting bit servers taking
advantage of past memory and I already
said this delay cyrillic alas traffic
and in this setting and en final point
is that in in information theory the
data is usually static so this is some
UHN to you by nature and the encoder
just takes that object and manipulates
it in order to transmitted over the
channel or is our is in control because
we have this feedback loop effectively
the encoder modifies the data at at
future time instances so in
communications that in the control world
and of course stability says it's a
major issue is there a course at this
level of analog is there a correspondent
to stability there's no stability in on
the information theory side situation
theory slide it's a good question well
the basic assumption in information
theory is that everything is stationary
I mostly care about stationary sources
no I guess that's one of the one of the
issues why it's difficult to do
okay so the question I'm gonna be
focusing on for the most of this talk is
actually really simple so we have a
scalar system and here a is between 1 &
2 and we can only transmit one bit per
channel use here and it's a noiseless
channel so we hear the bits are labeled
plus and minus really doesn't matter how
you label them so you only only transmit
one of the two possibilities and the
question is can we achieve bounded cost
with this one bit each time instance you
transmit one bit
very very very simple question it's kind
of surprising that it hasn't been
completely answered your state may
Vulcan yes yes so this so this system is
discrete-time sampled system which which
which which values are real values
exactly and what we want we want to
design a controller which which exactly
it takes as its informational input only
one of these two values yeah exactly
this is something about how this relates
to the questions at an anti house he was
also very good yes
why did not answer this question
well there's been a lot of work in this
direction however actually I'm gonna
talk about it later
so the achievability schemes here use
variable and so they allow to send more
bits at some time instances and fewer
bits at other time instances then it's
much easier to to show an achievability
result so here what we are asking is
what if we don't have this luxury but if
we always what if we always send one bit
per channel yes exactly so here we
assume that X naught also the initial
state has some probability density as
well and the eyes also have probability
density the density just mean oh yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah so exactly so this
this mean square error is is a function
let's expect that the mean square is a
function of your of your control
strategy like of your UT exactly yes so
that's a very important point so the
company we don't we do not put any
restrictions on this controller or in
color so we allow full my full usage of
memory of the past and actually this is
very essential here that that this
control I'm going to show you the scheme
that it leverages the memory
does anything change if you have the
channel between the controller and the
system oh it changes very much here it's
a completely different problem becomes
completely different probably much more
complicated I was gonna say a few words
at the end about it yeah
okay so formally we can introduce this
fundamental limit so M star as the
minimum is the minimum M such that
exists a causal quantizer account
controller which pair which has M levels
and I choose bounded bounded cost in
terms of better moments
and so this is the result so if we if we
eyes are independent that I have bounded
alpha moments than for any better less
than alpha the minimum number of
quantization points to achieve but
amongst abilities is floor of a plus one
with particular is it our case yeah so
if you have a stable system so a is less
than one then this is not interesting so
we can get away without sending no
information at all I'm equal so on it
corresponds to zero bids if a is between
1 and 2 and then AM is 2 which means one
bit I'm gonna talk about that yeah all
that I looked at bounded disturbances
again that's another that's another an
important distinction
[Music]
so interesting that you don't have any
distributional assumption exactly yeah
the bounded Manuel boundedness of
moments is the only thing we need
actually for this at your ability so
four corners that's interesting four
corners mean we need existence of
density if if we eyes do not have
density then then you can actually do
better than this but for for
achievability we don't don't need any
further assumptions yeah so alpha is so
alpha is we assume that we eyes have a
half density with visible or actually
with here we don't assume density we
assume that V is have bound at alpha
moment I agree I'm saying some posters
you guys have a second moment yes then a
becomes maybe less relevant because beta
is already supposed to be so if alpha is
it second it's true then then what we
are talking about this stability in
terms of any moment which is slightly
less than than two so better is like I
alpha min a small Epsilon
oh it's it's it's not only better it's
only a it's the only possibility yeah
I'm I was you might get some benefits
from trying to trying to group similar
together yes so this corresponds to
viable lands indeed it's it's it's
easier yeah so this is what previous
schemes did okay Oh like you mean like
small time sharing yeah yeah you could
do that yes you can do that absolutely
yeah causality means oh yeah so I'm
level comes like yes so so this is just
a more general case of this saying we're
so we were looking at a control and in
color so in this case it's only one bit
but in that case it's it can be like log
n bits causality just means that we we
choose this mappings based on infinite
memory of the past but we cannot look in
the future
okay so let me tell you what's known
about this problem because as I said
it's been quite extensively studied so
the very basic cases is bounded
disturbances so if V is I bounded almost
surely by some constant and actually
it's a very easy problem that has been
solved and the minimum required for
stability is indeed what what we said it
should be yeah this strategy is very
simple time invariant I'm gonna show you
it to you in a second
so first I'd like to show you this so
what if we don't have any rate
constraints so it's infinite capacity
channel we can transmit reals over it
then the nodes just look look here so
what we want to bring this X to 0 so
what is the best control action that you
can choose well the best one you can
choose actually to to cancel are to
cancel what you observed and and that is
gonna result in minimum I mean minimum
mean square error cost equal to the
variance of your noise your additive
noise and so this corresponds to the
theoretical I seems is that ok so so
let's let's just remember this so this
is the optimal control when we do not
have any rate constraints
okay and this is the scheme the easy
time-invariant scheme which achieves the
the limit for bounded disturbances so we
are looking at an unstable system here
and and bounded noise and the scheme
does the following
so here we are going to pretend the
controller is is going to pretend that
whatever it observes it's actually the
true the true state and this has a name
it's called certainty equivalence
control right so X I hat here is a
quantized version so we just cancel the
quantized version as if it was the true
one and then you can and so what you do
here is you have this uncertainty
uncertainty interval and and you have em
em level quantizer so you divided into
em levels and and so you can compute and
so if X I was in less than C I then then
with this control Y and X the next state
is going to be it's going to be in this
region and then if we just look at it at
this reissue then it's really easy to
see that that in order to make this
thing decrease you need the m to be
greater than a I have to make it to make
it to go to zero and right otherwise
it's going to diverge
otherwise the sequence is gonna diverge
and then and then so from here
immediately obtain obtain the M star
yeah and you cannot you cannot do any
better than this this is also really
easy like volume division argument it
could be anything so this is an
achievable scheme so we are saying this
control achieves the best we can do it
yeah yes
yes so actually this is this is also a
difference is how control people usually
think about problems because control in
control community people usually look at
at the optimal strategy and then they
study the studies say the properties of
that optimal strategy so here we are
taking an information theoretic approach
which is to say we're going to look at
the ball we're going to look at a shoe
ability and we're going to look at
converse and then we're going to try to
to to prove that those are close
together or coincide in some cases
yeah yeah so here yeah it's yeah I'm
gonna talk more about that if I have
time
okay yeah so this this establishes so
this argument establishes this a sim
data for the bounded case
that's what the idea is we need to
divide that uncertainty interval into
sufficiently many Croatian points so as
to beat this multiplicative growth of
the system so now our I'd like to talk
about unbound and disturbances because
this is where this is the problem
becomes fundamentally different from
from what is known so here so imagine we
have we now have a PDF which which has
tails I can unbound it and assume that
we just try to to do the same thing we
did before just run the same quantizer
as we did before so choose to -
representation levels just if if the
system state is in this area you have
play this control and if it's if it's
negative if we apply that control ok so
just trying to do the same time
invariant strategy unfortunately it's
gonna fail why because eventually since
your noise is unbounded with probability
1 but we remember we're running this
system for a very long time
eventually it's probability 1 you're
gonna encounter a noise realization
which is gonna which is going to be
outside of your conjectured bounds and
so at that from that point on your
system is gonna run out of control so
you make sure that is a result which
says if you have unbounded disturbances
then then you cannot use time invariant
quantizers so any time invariant visor
is finitely many levels cannot achieve
bounded cost
so the only the only option it seems
like is a zooming type quantizer which
was it reduced by a bracket and
Lieberson and and so we use this zoom in
i exhuming idea so what what it does is
that we test when whether we stay within
the bounds and then we zoom out and so
it's an adoptive strategy I'm gonna show
you the strategy if X 0 is unbounded
density yes yeah
okay so this is you mind there about our
problem I'm gonna show you how we
stabilize it with one bit so this is the
overview
yeah it's a time time variant the
encoder is the time varying threshold in
rule so the threshold actually has two
it seems like we need to worry the
threshold with this time and and then
the the controller uses the following
strategy
so here CI is is so the this interval is
the estimated interval containing X I
okay so this is something that the
controller computes going to conjectures
so it's it pretends it acts as if X I
was indeed contained in that interval
and then this sine I is is the estimated
sine of X I so so effectively if you if
you remember the strategy for the bond
that case it's so this does exactly
exactly that so if X I was bounded by CI
then this is exactly the same strategy
as as in the bounded case
and of course the problem here is the
the issue here is to devise a strategy
of updating this see is what we do and
and actually sign here sign William
it's either plus one minus one and we
also allow is zero so it's it's zero and
we cannot say much about the sign yeah
so we want to design I want to decide
so effectively deciding this CI is
everything what we want to do we want to
look at the past and and to make a
decision about what is the likely CI
where where where what is the likely
interval uncertainty interval where x
lives so it's it's a schedule strategy
so what we do we choose K and for okay
moves we we just pretend that we are in
the bounded case so this is called
normal or zoomin mode where we just
operate as if as if not the noise was
bounded then for one time step we miss
the probe time step where we test
whether our conjectures were indeed true
that's why forth and and the most of the
time and it's going to be correct but
sometimes we're going to find that the
noise actually produced a large
realization and so we are outside of our
desired bounds and in that case we are
going to enter this time we're in
emergency or zoom out mode this is this
is a random this is a random stopping
time actually it's not it's not a fixed
constant so K here is fixed case
something we choose
beforehand but but tau is is something
that is decided
in real-time
so in normal mode as I already said we
just pretend that the noises are bounded
and the encoder in this case it the
threshold is just zero so we just
thought put the sign of FXI is our
threshold the output plus if it's
greater than zero and we output minus if
it's less than zero okay I forgot to say
the noise here is zero mean it's not
zero minutes you just shift yeah this is
the threshold rule in this case and in
color just outputs the sign and the
control acts as in the bound of case so
this is we pretend that excise lives
within CI we divided them to
quantization bins and we output either
you know this value R or that value
depending on the side
it's predetermined once you know c1
right way we start its predetermined
exactly it splits it follows this
formula and then the end only becomes
random when you enter the emergency mode
yeah exactly so here it's predetermined
sake here everything is predetermined
and most of the time this is going to be
the case so most of the time I got the
BP rating in this normal mode as if
everything was bounded and just
sometimes we are going to be entering
this red emergency area okay so this is
the probe so after those key normal
steps what we are going to do we are
going to test whether the X is actually
staying within the desired bonds all
right so here we computed this C is
according to this predetermined sequence
and here since it's always a nonzero
probability that noise is larger than
what we what we expected we're just
going to test whether X is within this
bond so that the quantizer here looks
like this
so this is your C CK so you output plus
if you are in this region and you know
put - if your outside person the
important part here is that it's a
schedule right so both both encoder and
control or no weather so at this point
the the controller knows that we are in
the probing mode so it knows how to
interpret this plus or minus and
actually they're encoded at this at this
time step it doesn't do anything it just
applies an all zero control so we
actually we use this this information
only to decide what to do next
so if the test came back as passed then
the round ends and we just start over
but otherwise so if it's if it's outside
of our desired bounds then we enter
emergency mode and again both both in
coherent controller I agree on this this
is the emergency mode so here what we do
we we repeatedly perform more tests so
we the tests look like this whether you
are staying in this region and we
increase so here P is some constant
which is again chosen beforehand and we
we pick this P you know beforehand and
then we just exponentially increase the
size of this interval and and eventually
you're gonna catch this data initially
the test is going to be passed and when
that happens you just go back to the
normal mode and you start over yes could
you just repeat for the noble night the
update equation to see invoked B could
you just remind me OB here is the
conjectured bound on VI so this it's
again it's a parameter which is set
before so B's is just that in the
beginning of times and it stays always
the same and it can be optimized so
think of B as some something that is
large enough so that if your noise looks
like this then then most of the time
it's gonna be inside of this is
something that can be adjusted do you
need most of whatever sorry yeah we need
this to be a large enough yeah this con
I mean our analysis is not super
optimized so yeah that's something that
I'm actually curious it's a constant
it's a constant that you just said it's
a constant that you just said
when you return to normal mode the
initial value of CI is what again some
small value yes we initially so we start
how do we start
so x1 is a times X naught plus you
we assume that we know something we know
the density maybe of this or the inter
distribution so so we assume that they
live somewhere yeah we start somewhere
okay so actually I don't have time of
course to go into analysis I just wanna
say a few words it's a probabilistic
analysis what we do we analyze the
result of each round so each each
variable-length round and the goal here
is to show that after around is
completed them but it is better the
moment tends to decrease compared to the
start of the round and what we need this
boundedness of alpha moment of VI to
show that the probability that the
emergency lasts as long as j is the case
indicates something like this that's we
use the fact that we exponentially the
increase this in this interval so this
interval that we test for and then there
are quite a few hoops to jump through so
xxi so this value is not a martingale so
it's kind of tricky to analyze directly
but so what we do we craft my dressing
sequence that he is a martingale and
then and then we use this bound on this
on this probability of that emergency
lasts as long as j to to bound the
conditional expectation of this much
it's very high-level over you just wanna
say that it extends and whereas
directions so final quantization is a
very straightforward extension so here
we really everything works the same way
and you use the actually uniform scalar
quantizer just there is a different
number of levels it's also generalizes
for correlated noise I know as long as
the noise covariance matrix has abounded
spectrum so higher dimension as well
high dimension the same star is still
here by recent a a now is is given by
this formula where lambda Amex is the m
eigen value stop here and maybe a let me
just say this that we also so I so today
I mostly talked about actually only
talked about this but but we also have
results on on this entire curve so the
bounds on this entire curve especially
the lower bound that is that works for
very January and you have an upper bound
that works for variable rate
equalization so one of them one of the I
think exciting open problems here is to
to see to have an ability result which
which tells us something about this
entire curve for for this scenario that
I talked about the fixed rate position
only since a one bit so can we say
something about about this entire curve
and the bounds that we have right now I
have to tweak word but but experiments
suggest that actually actually the lower
bound that we have is pretty tight so
experimentally we tried running
lloyd-max quantizer that and the lower
bound
it's very close to that so an analysis
would be interesting
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I mean yeah so here's zoom in zoom
out idea it's been around yes so the
nose is the analysis so first it's not
it's not the same it's not this I guess
the idea itself that you need to zoom
out and eat if you know if they if the
system is far from what you can Jack she
ate this so that has been around but
they this particular strategy that K
steps and then you test so that that is
new as well as the analysis the fact
that it actually achieves the optimum on
the number of us also the M star so what
we wanted we wanted to have an answer
about what would this M star is yeah
yeah so they but the ideas of of of
zooming in zooming out have been around
all the knowledge of a yes oh yeah so if
a is larger than yeah
yeah I think if yeah if you use a that
is larger it's gonna work actually yeah
yeah it's it's I mean all the analysis
that's yeah yeah it works if the other
direction